kommen wir zu diesem thema in vielen
teilen südeuropas sind wegen anhaltender
trockenheit und hitze waldbrände
ausgebrochen die teils kilometer großen
feuerwalzen verwandeln ganze
urlaubsregionen der mittelmeerländer in
verkohlte landschaften und vielerorts
müssen die menschen auch evakuiert
werden rettungskräfte feuerwehren
katastrophen und zivilschutz sind im
dauereinsatz bekämpfen die flammen auch
aus der luft eine besserung ist bislang
nicht in sicht ganz im gegenteil
[Musik]
das was sie hier sehen liebe zuschauer
waren einmal urlaubsorte portugal
spanien kroatien und griechenland
auch in frankreich und italien ein
flammen entfernung so schlimm wie noch
nie an urlaub ist nicht zu denken hier
geht es ums nackte überleben
die feuerwalze rollt über südeuropa
portugal mehr als 3000 feuerwehrleute
kämpfen am donnerstag gemeinsam mit den
verzweifelten portugiesischen bürgern
gegen mehrere waldbrände in der
ortschaft beim popstar spritzen die
bewohner mit gartenschläuchen ihre rasen
und dächer ihrer häuser ab allein in
dieser woche werden in portugal etwa 100
quadratkilometer land verbrennen
135 menschen darunter 70 feuerwehrleute
werden bisher verletzt zum glück noch
keine toten spanien auch hier kämpfen
feuerwehrleute und soldaten weiter gegen
einen flächenbrand in der westlichen
region extremadura mehr als 34
quadratkilometer sind bereits vernichtet
hunderte menschen mussten ihre häuser
verlassen
mehr als 400 einsatzkräfte stemmen sich
gegen das
kroatien auch hier ist die situation
mehr als kritisch die feuer sind bis auf
wenige meter an die orte wo diese und
ras lina herangekommen
ich habe das haus im januar gekauft und
seitdem hier in ras nina gelebt in
deutschland habe ich alles verkauft das
hier ist mein ganzes leben das war mein
leben
[Musik]
dann sah man so schon auf der anderen
seite dass das feuer die ersten häuser
an der bergregion erreicht als edition
zeigten ja und nicht ganze minute später
war das feuer schon quasi bei uns auf
der anderen straßenseite der brandrauch
wurde dann wirklich so massiv dass die
ganze sonne verdunkelt wurde es war
quasi wie in der nacht bin wirklich so
überrascht und der geschwindigkeit wie
sich das ausgebreitet hat nur massiv
also ich war ganz dramatisch unsere
kinder sind von dem ganzen ereignis so
schwer betroffen die sind
ja so sprach muss darüber dass von jetzt
auf gleich wirklich alles zu ende sein
alles türkei auf der halbinsel dacia im
südwesten sind acht löschflugzeuge 14
helikopter und 103 löschfahrzeuge im
einsatz
mehrere häuser werden evakuiert berichte
über verletzte gibt es noch kein
griechenland bei löscharbeiten stürzt
ein helikopter ins meer als die
besatzung wasser zur brandbekämpfung
aufnehmen will
zwei insassen kommen ums leben der pilot
wird später gerettet schwer verletzt in
ein krankenhaus gebracht
auch zwei weitere besatzungsmitglieder
können geborgen werden
urlaubsorte die sonst einem paradies
gleich in diesem jahr ein blick in die
hölle
bild reporterin clara becker ist für uns
in kroatien ganz in der nähe wo die
brände gewütet haben klara wir haben das
video gesehen deutsche touristen fliehen
vor dem flammeninferno
und du bist genau auf dem parkplatz wo
dieses video aufgenommen wurde wie groß
ist die schneise der verwüstung
ja die verwüstung sieht man hier rundum
rabbiner wirklich überall also wir
stehen jetzt genau richtig hier auf dem
platz wo gestern noch die autos standen
von urlaubern die hier einfach sich ein
bisschen abkühlen wollten im wasser und
ja es sind dann alle menschen von oben
runter gerannt aus dem dorf hier runter
gerannt als sie gesehen haben dass
dieses feuer nicht mehr zu bekämpfen ist
dass es wirklich außer kontrolle geraten
ist um sich hier am wasser in sicherheit
zu bringen und das auch genau richtig
denn wenn wir jetzt drei schritte
wirklich nur nach vielleicht fünf
weitergehen dann sieht man hier wie nah
das feuer war hier liegen boote die
komplett ausgebrannt sind verkohlt sind
wenn wir etwas nach links einmal
schwenken sieht man wie diese komplette
fläche bäume büsche alles komplett
abgebrannt ist das heißt man sieht die
menschen haben es genau richtig gemacht
sie haben sich hier ans wasser gerettet
und wären sie nur vielleicht 15 meter
weiter weg gestanden hätten sie in
diesen flammen mitten drin gestanden
also es war wirklich eine dramatische
situationen die man gestern hier
wahrscheinlich erlebt hat und ja dieser
ort in dem wir jetzt hier stehen es auch
fast ausgestorben die menschen wurden
mit boten hier aus diesem hafen
evakuiert wir haben auch noch ein paar
deutsche also ein auch ein paar autos
mit deutschen kennzeichen gesehen die
hier überstürzt stehengelassen wurden
das heißt alleine an dieser szenerie
kann man ja
sehen wie wie schnell das alles gestern
gehen musste wie gefährlich die
situation war und man sah auch eben ganz
gut und eindrücklich hinter dir die
wohnhäuser wie nah sie auch zu dem brand
stehen wie ist denn die momentane
situation generell in kroatien gibt es
noch touristen oder auch anwohner die
eingeschlossen sind von den flammen
die feuer sind jetzt aktuell unter
kontrolle gebracht und gelöscht in
dieser region es gibt natürlich noch
viele touristen hier in dieser region
einige wurde neben zeitweise evakuiert
manche sind schon zurückgekommen hier in
diesem ort sind ein paar einheimische
sogar geblieben die uns gesagt haben wir
sind nicht weggegangen unsere häuser
waren betroffen natürlich hatten wir
angst aber wir wollten unsere häuser
sollten sie hier nicht zurücklassen es
gibt viele touristen noch hier in dieser
gegend die jetzt aktuell auch wieder
hier in zurückkehren können allerdings
ist es auch einfach ja also man ist es
jetzt viertel nach neun hier ist es
eigentlich noch recht früh und trotzdem
prallte wirklich schon die sonne runter
ist richtig stechend und heiß und in den
nächsten tagen besteht eben auch die
gefahr dass solche brände erneut
entstehen können und wir haben auch mit
einem menschen sprechen können daher
gestern vor ort war und der hat uns
erzählt gegen mittag dachte man
eigentlich dass das ganze schon relativ
gut unter kontrolle gebracht wurde und
dann hat sich plötzlich der wind gedreht
und diese flammen sind wirklich
innerhalb von wenigen minuten haben sich
extrem ausgebreitet waren nicht mehr zu
bändigen und so schnell kann das in so
einer situation daneben gehen vielen
dank klarer becker live aus kroatien für
diese eindrücke
sind dass die sommer brände wie wir sie
jedes jahr erleben oder ist das ein
ungewöhnliches phänomen fragen wir
unseren bild wetterexperten karsten
brandt kassen gefüllt ist dieses jahr
besonders schlimm mit den bränden ist
das nur ein gefühl wir sehen nicht
gerade am rhein der sehr wenig wasser
hat im moment ja genau das hinter mir
ist der rein und da sieht man natürlich
auch schon die ursache für die brände im
mittelmeerraum aber teilweise dann ja
auch bei uns in deutschland der rhein
ist ein bisschen ein spiegelbild ja ja
also die wir haben und die die
trockenheit ist extrem im mittelmeerraum
haben wir eine einheit das liegt an den
hohen temperaturen also erstmal der
frühlingsregen der war etwas schwächer
und dann haben wir
sehr hohe temperaturen gab mai juni juli
mittelmeerraum sehr heiß etwas über 40
grad nicht nur dort auch bei uns hier in
deutschland temperaturen im juni 23 grad
über dem durchschnitt und ihr müsst euch
vorstellen wenn die temperaturen höher
sind es wird mehr wasser dann wird das
bisschen wasser was aus dem früher aus
dem winter noch im boden ist sie raus
gepresst morgen ist es so dass wenn die
pflanze versucht an wasser ranzukommen
mit 5 in bar in dem trockenen boden hier
in deutschland rücken muss oder saugen
muss um überhaupt an wasser hat extreme
dürre man muss von dürr besprechen und
der rein wie gesagt interview sieht man
relativ gut man sieht er hat
niedrigwasser das hat dann einsatz noch
da wo vielleicht auswirkungen auch auf
die transporte ja also die schiffe
fragen dann nicht mehr mit voller ladung
hier den rhein herunter und auch solo
elbe weser ist das nämlich sbm sie
müssten die müssen dann die ladung
halbieren zum teil weil einfach
natürlich wenig wasser in ein grünes und
entsprechend so vielen
kassen viele menschen machen sich jetzt
gerade auch den weg in den urlaub wo ist
die brandgefahr denn in europa besonders
schlimm und wie sieht es eigentlich
momentan auch dann hier bei uns in
deutschland aus wir erinnern uns vor
einem monat ca da gab es ja schon mal
viele waldbrände hier auch in der nähe
von berlin in beelitz zu machen wie ist
die lage ja also runter tief wie gesagt
man kann in den urlaub fahren macht euch
darum jetzt keine sorgen
aber und das ist nicht der richtige tipp
machen sie diese waldbrände sind ja sehr
lokal unbedingt mit der rezeption mit
dem reise mit den nachbarn trinken und
man hat das ja in kroatien der gerade
sehr schön gesehen das ist wie gesagt
eine ganz normale geschichte und
manchmal entstehen die brände wirklich
innerhalb von minuten stunden werden
dann kommen dann aus sagt und all weil
der wind ein der wind ist dann zum teil
ein lokales phänomen deswegen ist ganz
wichtig wenn man den mittel warum
unterwegs in griechischen inseln oder in
spanien irgendwo dass man kontakte
nachbarn hat die informationen habe und
das match war schweigen also
mitverfolgen wie ist die situation vor
ort also nicht national oder europaweit
sondern lokal dass man informiert wird
dass man dann relativ schnell handeln
kann wenn man dann aus dem ort raus muss
und aus den häusern raus muss also ganz
wichtiger tipp möglich in kontakt
bleiben mit dem reiseveranstalter und
bord und und immer wie gesagt die
situation vor ort beobachten da geht es
wir kriegen nächste woche diese
hitzeglocke aus von der iberischen
halbinsel ab dh besonders der westen
also es kommt am sonntag mit 30 bis 33
grad im rheintal ran also ich hab hier
stehe wenn wir morgen wenn wir am
sonntag dann über 30 grad haben wir
werden im ruhrgebiet 33 grad am montag
ins am mittwoch zieht diese glocke über
deutschland hinweg wir sind noch nicht
ganz sicher ob es dann wirklich grad
oder mehr gibt oder ob er bei 37 38 watt
liegen das werden wir sehen auf jeden
fall die erste woche des jahres im
nächste woche und dann haben wir auch
wieder wald gefahren müssen sehr
vorsichtig sein also große nächste woche
sagte bild wetter experte karsten brandt
vielen dank bitteschön